yeah welcome to this video playing
Alonso mostly from no way I mean no this
is not normal right Denmark Denmark at
least I spoilage okay got a sloth again
but also on the if Alonso mostly is some
person I should know I mean it's not his
name some some other person okay we've
got this laughs again with e3 and so on
okay at this earlier maybe this is a
good line or viable line for black after
all I don't really am I don't really
know that that line must admit Quincy to
we had this before and then I thought if
I've okay cannot do that because g6
saying if this guy plays that as well
then probably the suspect this is is
this all a book line and I just don't
know it okay something else what D 5
isn't e5 a good move maybe mmm ok plan
it's not it's not so clean up you more
wait okay the thing is d5 if he takes c3
I take you six cell this looks like a
good move and our waiter can play Knight
b6 song 96 I don't want that let's um
hmm try to grab the second bishop here
the only thing is I'm not really young
I'm not down not very well developed and
he's got the chances of course to to
block their this isolated pawn it just
wants to keep the pod sir very very
greedy but ok so the question is if i
take deform rook c8 maybe i'm just just
tied down and okay I could play be three
okay mom let's take it don't uh spend
hours
yeah two bishops are nice but it's a
very aesthetic bone structure ig4 might
be a problem Oh is your grouping hmm
interesting interesting play going to
see Sixers probably good
wow this looks better a lot so ma'am I
should have taken a bit of time IAM we
can play a five or maybe takes and play
you five now this is very bad
not sure what's the best even okay
hmm yeah this isn't really am doing much
my butt is not a five threatened all
kinds of stuff is is on
wouldn't mind a draw him and so I don't
have time is there some way to continue
to play the Cimini threatening to take
here I come on let's play some other
move I don't want to make it wrong it's
probably probably just crap here I mean
why does not better but I'm just want to
continue the game I always wonder if he
may be can take a play 5 i'll play you 5
35 36 a oh please this is an idea
okay yeah okay at least I have a 72
attack I mean I've got my weaknesses as
well so it's not clear cut or something
but I have some some idea at least how
to how to play take a seven
so after all this yep can play Bishop g5
at the end our way to have Bishop a form
Bishop f4 of course I queen bee three
you can play it anyway oh I'm just the
one is singing this is stupid I decades
it's not not like I'm losing instantly
or something but it just just a stupid
stupid play
hmm yep I stopped trying to
we need to cover the second rank 9 c 3
i've got Roxy too yeah yeah I just I
just lost our move basically with all
this nonsense and roof is important here
check
yeah not exactly comfortable to play
climb morning yeah and then i defied the
enter
I can just take em play 94 but both
pieces hanging no it's not what okay
cover your form quickly I can play
complain i th five check game wrong oh
but lucky at the end to get the draw tip
yeah okay it wasn't it wasn't a good
position anyway and I should have maybe
taken the drawn it didn't I didn't want
to it was a bit dicey of course yeah I
forgot that this actually attacks to the
rock ram this was the problem i had had
hit this intended out it's it's a look
so Bishop f4 is of course nonsense I
must take care here and now Brooksie one
or something or take the rook c1
something like this 95 treated that you
protect this and no I don't know just
just just to move here it should be fine
it's a member sandd
it's clear I'm Ambrose this is a good
night against a not great bishop but I
have much better chances to defend here
because I've got the rukon the seventh
and I have he needs to be careful that I
don't get to get counterplay I mean he
cannot let's say double on the second
rank or something it's not not easy to
do so I've got pretty decent drawing
chances it's not fun to play but it's a
pretty decent yeah thanks for watching